cuando tenía ocho años recuerdo con
emoción esperar los cursos de verano
ahí era el momento donde podía aprender
nuevas cosas pero sobre todo conocer
nuevos amigos sabía que ese verano iba a
ser diferente e iba a ser especial y no
me equivoqué habían abierto una clase de
computación para niños corrí y me
inscribí y en una sala muy al estilo de
café internet recuerdo la primera vez
que conocí una computadora me acuerdo de
un monitor gigante marca las k teclas
abultadas y un mouse que para mi corta
edad pensaba que era arte de magia que
una bolita hiciera aparecer una flecha
en aquella pantalla
después de estar todo ese verano
aprendiendo word powerpoint y crear una
snoopy configuración métricas en paint
corrí a mi casa y les pedí a mis mapas
que por favor de cumpleaños navidad
janucá reyes y cualquier otra
celebración quiero una computadora
quién iba a pensar que en aquella edad
iba a conocer algo que sería algo muy
apasionante para mí pero sobre todo que
iba a cambiar mi vida
soy dani gonzález como dijeron soy una
emprendedora soñadora y apasionada por
transformar mi entorno con la educación
y con la tecnología
estoy sumamente convencida de que todo
lo que podemos imaginar lo podemos crear
actualmente soy paris master y fundadora
de code park y la forma más divertida
para aprender para el futuro donde niñas
y niños desde temprana edad no solamente
aprenden ciencia y tecnología a través
de fiestas divertidas sino que ven todo
el potencial que pueden hacer desde que
ellos son pequeños
si hace algunos ayer es mi bien han
dicho que yo iba a emprender y que iba a
tener algo por mi propia cuenta ni
siquiera lo hubiera imaginado y mucho
menos que sería en un área que me
apasiona y me gusta pero que sería en la
tecnología
quién iba a decir que será una persona
inquieta una persona terca pero sobre
todo dispuesta al cambio me iba a
emprender me iba a preparar para
emprender
también he pensado que todas estas
características siempre me han dado como
algo importante para las decisiones que
toman y todo comenzó cuando fui a la
universidad ahí fue cuando comenzó
realmente esta pasión por la que yo
quería hacer muchas cosas diferentes y
encontrar mi camino principalmente
entonces cuando me fui a monterrey
porque yo soy de saltillo ustedes no
están ustedes para saberlo ni yo para
contarles pero realmente quería saber si
si estudiar ciencias de la comunicación
es lo que yo quería hacer toda la vida
no sabían que iba a trabajar no sabía
que me quería dedicar e incluso pensé sí
sí eso había sido una buena decisión
cuando ya estaba en la carrera me puse a
encontrar este camino esta pasión y
descubrirla me metí a diferentes clases
a diferentes cursos a diferentes grupos
estudiantiles para realmente ver si eso
era lo que me gustaba y cuando realmente
ya había descubrió he descubierto cuál
era mi pasión que eran las relaciones
públicas y crear eventos la vida me puso
un reto
y era que pues mis papás me habían dicho
que en ese momento estaban pasando por
una gran situación financiera por lo que
yo tenía que empezar a ayudar a
contribuir como buena foránea para
mantenerme y la verdad yo pensaba que
eso era como un gran balde de agua fría
porque lo que yo quería hacer que era
hacer eventos que hacer conciertos pues
no me ofrecían un trabajo remunerado
sino nada más prácticas profesionales y
lo que yo tenía que hacer pues era
encontrar un trabajo que me diera pues
este dinero para yo poder mantener
pero me encanta una frase que como diría
mi abuelita si la vida no te da lo que
tú quieres crea
y así fue que me puse a encontrar un
trabajo y que cree en la realidad es que
no me habían dado el único puesto que
sobraba que era subir contenido a unas
páginas web y como yo les he comentado
pues lo que yo quería hacer era hacer
eventos era hacer conciertos por lo que
les dije que pues yo lo quería hacer
entonces empecé a crear un área
inexistente en ese puesto de trabajo y
me dediqué a hacer eventos y congresos
en ese momento porque a mis 20 años pues
um es joven es inocente y me di cuenta
que yo me podía quitar esa venda de los
ojos para decir claro que puedo porque a
veces somos esos víctimas de nuestra
propia vida y pensamos pues ya que ya ni
modo esto es lo que me pasó vivir y para
poder ilustrar les mejor lo que estoy
hablando me gustaría ponerles un pequeño
vídeo
conforme ha transcurrido a medida que
estudia saliente mente es otra cosa hay
dos no así es esto hay los que quieren
estudiar de todo hay quien es cierto
pues sí señor en la mente humana por eso
y para más por el arte para la filosofía
para la literatura para la ciencia para
las artes marciales para lo que se
quiera somos la especie más evolucionada
de este planeta más capaz podemos crear
fuertes que van al espacio podemos
salvar vidas podemos crear robots
podemos que la literatura un chingo de
cosas el ideal del hombre universal que
tenía leonardo da vinci que tenía miguel
ángel que tenía friedrich nietzsche el
potencial de la mente humana es infinito
y quieres estimar coste y te dice hoy
wey pues tú quieres hacer todos vos y
cabrón porque tengo una mente humana y
me da la capacidad hay que utilizar el
cerebro humano para estudiar de todo
tienes curiosidad de aprender esto
aprenderlo tienes
el nombre fíjense toda la gente
y decía que fíjense toda la gente que te
está diciendo que no lo hagas y que
dicen y tú quieres hacer muchas cosas y
dicen pues si tú quieres hacer lo mismo
siempre y así como como acuerdo con este
compás pero menos enojada que si
nosotros no somos las personas que nos
retamos cómo vamos a saber realmente lo
que nosotros queremos y así después de
crear esta área inexistente que les
decía en una oficina de gobierno me
dediqué a organizar eventos masivos
eventos para jóvenes eventos grandes
para más de 15.000 personas y en uno de
ellos me di cuenta no me equivoqué
eso es lo que realmente quiero hacer
toda mi vida que era organizar que era
crear y descubrir cosas nuevas pero por
primera vez en mi vida me había dado
cuenta que yo quería emprender porque yo
sabía que yo lo podía hacer y que mejor
pues organizando eventos por mi cuenta
y así fue mi primer emprendimiento se
llamó blogger fest donde invitamos a
vídeo bloggers de youtube a que
hiciéramos un evento grande mágico donde
pues invitamos a sus fans y los
mezclaremos con música en la
organización de este evento me di cuenta
que las personas lloraban por estos
youtubers que realmente se emocionaban y
fue de verdad el momento que me enamoré
y me apasionó lo que puede causar el
internet y la tecnología
[Música]
y después de estar viendo todo el
impacto que puede tener estos medios
dije por qué no yo puedo hacer redes
sociales puedo hacer contenido y la vida
misma me demostró que nada está por
escrito y que es de sabios cambiar de
opinión y a pesar de que yo había tenido
tantos retos y yo pensaba que desde
ahora lo que ya quería hacer toda la
vida me enfrenté para decir ahora quiero
hacer esto
y es por eso que después empecé a
emprender diferentes proyectos con
diferentes temáticas en redes sociales
diferentes empresas quiero compartirles
lo que he aprendido
hoy no les vengo a decir que manden toda
la fregada que ya se pongan emprender
que si no que realmente no dejen que
pase un día más sin que descubran cual
es aquella pasión que es lo que los
motiva que es lo que les llama que es lo
que realmente ustedes quieren hacer
no sé si ustedes sepan pero es
preocupante una de cada tres personas
que trabajan en méxico odia su trabajo
y tan solo el 60 el 67 por ciento de las
personas encuestadas en 2017 que tienen
un trabajo están dispuestos a cambiarse
porque ya no aguantan al jefe ya no
saben qué quieren hacer o no lo retan
suficiente y tan sólo el 12 por ciento
de las personas mexicanas que trabajan
creen que pues sí están siendo sumamente
retados en su trabajo nosotros somos
parte de la estadística o estamos
haciendo algo para nosotros cambiar no
sé si se acuerdan pero vida sólo hay una
y nosotros venimos a esta a esta tierra
para poder inspirar a las demás personas
pero sobre todo hacer las cosas que nos
apasionan y nos hacen felices
el éxito no se alcanza buscando likes
quiero que de una vez por todas nos
demos cuenta que tenemos que trabajar
día con día para buscar qué es lo que
nos apasiona qué es lo que nos gusta que
disfrutemos los caminos buenos y malos
que no podemos ser hipócritas con
nosotros y matar esa llama que nos dice
por dentro que tenemos que hacer algo
es válido poder cambiar de opinión es
válido poder decir esto ya no quiero
esto ya no me gusta pero que sobre todo
podamos decir yo también lo puedo hacer
cuántos de ustedes han pensado que este
tema de emprender es solo para algunos
pocos incluso la vida misma nos está
diciendo que si es necesario tenemos que
romper nuestros sueños que de las
pasiones no vamos a vivir y la realidad
es que todos podemos hacer algo al
respecto
me gusta decir esta frase porque creo
fielmente en ella
si nosotros atentamos contra nosotros
contra nosotros mismos y nuestra esencia
es como si muriera mos en vida por lo
que tenemos que trabajar tenemos que
empezar a decir claro lo puedo hacer lo
puedo hacer por las tardes lo puede ser
por la mañana lo puede ser por la noche
pero hagamos realmente que las cosas
sucedan podemos trabajar podemos lo que
les decía actuando trabajando y haciendo
muchas cosas para que nosotros digamos
esto es lo que realmente quiero hacer
emprender es más que tener una idea
emprender es pasión es convicción que en
conjunto con la inspiración puede
derribar cualquier barrera a veces es
muy fácil ver solamente por encima no
ver que hay mucho trabajo por detrás es
como si estuviéramos viendo la punta del
iceberg e ignoramos que en el fondo hay
un sinfín de detonadores que están
listos para ser accionados
después de estar emprendiendo diferentes
proyectos con diferentes temáticas me
doy cuenta que en el hoy está descubrir
realmente cuál es cuál es nuestra
verdadera pasión muchas gracias
[Aplausos]